it's a war zone everywhere you go is
going to have an element of risk that's
their lost toehold
there was this frantic activity
everyone's on red alert we were a
sitting duck
she'd been groomed for just one week
her story was remarkable
[Music]
with it out knowing that this was the
dismantling of the whole of the Islamic
state caliphate an area pretty much the
size of Britain the Caliphate was in its
dying stages we set out to try and
capture that the road that led to this
point has been a bloody violent an
extremely destructive one they had
pushed the Islamic state to within a
really small area it was about two
streets but they had sacrificed an awful
lot by the time we went there the final
fighters were in a fairly small pocket
the main concern at that stage was areas
that had been cleared but all the
fighters had not necessarily been caught
or surrendered their immortal still
being fired randomly soldiers are
milling around it's a war zone so
everywhere you go is going to have an
element of risk in northern Syria there
are large distances to drive lots of
checkpoints as we approach the frontline
the towns were pretty much destroyed you
can see some signs of life people do
still live there the coalition really
got a move on and they pushed through
all these villages smashing their way
through and there was no way they
cleared everything that meant that many
areas were still extremely unsafe
it's more of a controlled environment
now but the danger now comes from those
supervisors okay we're being told to
walk exactly in this guy's path because
they're worried about mines this is only
very recently been cleared they say
they've cleared it but they cannot be
100% certain that is safe this was - -
lived in here this is very typical of of
the Islamic state digging tunnels and
they also had smashed through holes in
the wall so they could get from building
to building so there's lots of drones
ahead there's walls being smashed down
the buildings of pop its marked with
bullet holes there's debris everywhere
you could see the sort of horridness
that have been evacuated sides are a
family probably stayed here because the
small toys left behind and in this
suitcase we see a little bit of a part
of a book with which is in French a
woman's glove a watch Calvin Klein watch
what appears to be part of a diary in
which they say that doesn't matter what
the amputations are the the injuries the
torture and imprisonment it's all worth
it for alle and there's a child's
drawing here which shows the Islamic
flag and a plane dropping bombs on
houses and it just gave you a glimpse
into what life must have been like for
these people who'd suddenly had to leave
we were taken as far as the coalition
forces we were waived were prepared to
take us we were told that you could
actually see - as they called it we were
taken to a high vantage point to be
honest if I hadn't seen it myself
I probably wouldn't believed it
they said you can see them you can see
is you can see them from where we stand
I was really impatient show me show me
what's what can you see that's their
last stronghold you could see women
dressed in black burgers
it was busier than I imagined it would
be there was this frantic activity of
people zipping across on motorbikes
appearing to get ready for something
there was a lot of activity you can see
movement on the streets
it does look eerie there was a tented
area where they believed civilians are
being held maybe they were being held as
human shields maybe they have nowhere
else to go I was also conscious of the
fact that we're visible to them we can
zoom in and see them making sure as hell
see us they still got weapons they still
pose a risk
the journey is a lot of barren desert a
lot of the time but there are villages
you go through and some of these
villages are known to be hotspots if you
like for sympathizers we were always
traveling in a two car convoy because of
the obvious security that that happened
if one or other of the cars broke down
we were driving our two vehicles and
just heard a cop
the longer were in this spot the more
chance we are of becoming a target and
we were a sitting duck
everyone's radars on red alert you don't
want to break down in an area which may
be insecure yeah it is Syria the risk is
that you don't realize that it's still
very very dangerous everyone's hand to
the pump to try and get it sorted when
you're me and you've got nothing to
offer in this situation you have to just
sit and hope that they get on with it
we were taken to a holding area in the
middle of the desert for those who had
managed to escape from the fighting
there was nothing there all these women
and children were all just sitting out
in the open air
the first thing that struck me was how
bleak the place was this huge white
windy desert scape
dozens of women and children
although worldly belongings in a few
bags it's just dusty and dirty human
excrement everywhere it's filthy
they've got no food they're given some
handouts but there's not a lot there
[Music]
we're trying to find people to talk to
to hear about what was inside where they
just come from how did they end up there
what can they tell us about the
situations in that last is pocket so we
found a young French woman she seemed
really talkative very ready to tell us
her entire story I was 15
big in my head are you talking Internet
Anna
only she'd been groomed for just one
week before she her mother her older
sister up and leaves their homes in
France and the other woman shows in her
early 20s and she'd already had two
husbands and was on her third one had
died was fighting the other had died in
a bomb she had two children she was
really hesitant to say it was the wrong
decision I have daughters the same age
as her and she was on her third marriage
already had two children had seen death
right up close and personal and she was
still talking about it being a positive
experience the children I thought was
something else there were a huge number
of them quite a few of them on their own
some of the children there were younger
than the Caliphate so they did not
choose to be there they were there
because the decision made by a a parent
or a relative they did not know where
they were what was going on among the
women and children there were other
people with injuries pretty serious
injuries too we saw a guy in a
wheelchair who had some horrific burns
on his face and was suspected of being a
fighter he wasn't saying very much but I
felt he was more alert that he was
letting on and certainly the the
coalition soldiers who were there
weren't having any of it
he had this surprisingly sophisticated
set of pins and I remember thinking how
on earth did he manage to do that
you know really Isolators is Enclave
that probably meant he was someone quite
important or significant within bis
hierarchy may be an important fighter or
a commander in the distance about 20 men
or so that been separated and about to
be processed and taken away they're
automatically assumed to be fighters
they were gonna go off to a prison every
journalist wanted to interview people
who've got a real insight into what it's
like inside the Calif element
how they got on how they got there what
made them go there
and we've managed to get access to three
of them we had been pushing for a number
of weeks to get access to some of these
British prisoners we had to agree to a
list of conditions not allowed to give
the location and the first who comes in
is an Irish citizen he looked very gaunt
then and pretty beaten down to be honest
we just don't know what we're gonna get
this guy he moved to the area brought
his family over from Ireland they
Alexander
okay these were people who came from the
heart of is territory considered to be
here in the in the most severe case
dangerous is supporting individuals are
you a terrorist
I'm not I'm not a terrorist
I'm more than a person I am
well I hope I'm a good husband and then
good father a now well in majority of
the people was forced to fight you don't
fight you don't eat I didn't fight I
didn't eat the British pharmacist who we
interviewed seemed quite shocked at what
was going on this is the Brit here in
the middle of nowhere
what's he doing here you know I'm not an
Isis fighter I'm not a dangerous person
I have hurt nobody
I have done nothing wrong other than
work in a hospital I don't think he
understood what a big deal of [ __ ] he
was in what do you want to happen to you
now I mean do you want to go back to
Britain I'd love to go back to Britain
yes the men we met the final prisoner he
was a British medic
he was also desperate to return to the
UK can I see your identity please sure
stem to the British government I would
humbly request for help really Isis took
part of my life away from me they
snatched me away from from everything
basically why am I still sitting in the
prison soon as one of them said yeah is
the worst mistake of my life
I don't really think it's up to us to
decide whether they're telling the truth
or not
I don't really understand the logic of
saying that we shouldn't interview these
people in the first place because if we
don't interview them we are not getting
a chance to challenge them ourselves to
hear from these people about whether it
is believable they just ended up in is
territory with honest and good intention
whether you believe that or not but we
wouldn't know that if we hadn't spoken
to them and don't think they had any
real idea of the venom that's facing
them sometimes where there's been big
conflict some of the most interesting
stories come from just outside the
battlefield we were told that they had
set up a sort of rehabilitation center
specifically for children who had been
identified by the Islamic state as Cubs
of the caliphate
these were the children that they wanted
to train and brainwash into being
they're soldiers of the future we went
straight into a classroom all the
children had been found in various
compromising positions some had been
found with suicide vests on some have
been found fighting and others were the
offspring of Caliphate leaders so they
were all identified as very very
vulnerable children peroxy acutely aware
that these boys are anything but normal
[Music]
they're learning about the solar system
but not long before they have weapons
all these children had had a very very
small world which was all around is now
they were learning about the huge big
world and the whole universe
there was a kind of lack of childlike
spark in quite a few of the children we
thought and they were clearly heavily
traumatized by whatever they had
experienced I can't imagine the stress a
child would be under especially if they
were taken to this area by someone they
trusted like a parent there was a very
little french-speaking boy who with 9
when he was taken to Syria by his father
this little boy stood out quite a lot
because he seemed very European he'd
somehow managed to survive but he had
this big black cloud over him one of the
boys spoke very calmly about how his
siblings had just been killed he sort of
said in a very way where my two brothers
got killed in a bombing and he just
mentioned it as something that had
happened he didn't know really what had
happened to his father and didn't seem
to want to talk about his father but he
talked aloft about his mother who had
been left behind and who had been taken
away from and who was still in Paris
[Music]
she'd obviously spent some time hand
making gifts she had selection of them
little bag bracelets little ties and
he'd written this letter to his mum with
a great big heart on the front telling
her how much he loved her young boy
reaching out his modern thousands of
miles he wanted us to try and find her
in Paris and hand it over to her we took
them from him with the hope that we try
and get them to his mum in Paris I
thought the last thing I do kind of make
sure I find that mother if he's missing
her this much she must definitely be
missing him
I thought before we even saw his mother
she's going to be quite emotional
[Music]
to
she was furious at her ex-husband she
thought he was just taking them away for
a couple of days they disappeared for
four years she didn't know exactly where
he was and watching pictures of him
absorbing every frame that was being
shown to that little boy who's a whole
world away she's desperate to get him
back
she was very emotional she knows that
her son has made this for her
and then when she got to the letter I
mean just on the outside of it is
emotional enough because there's a great
big heart with an arrow through it
written by her son who she hasn't been
able to hold for four years and she was
too emotional to read it so she asked
Sophie our producer to read it out for
her I can't imagine what she's feeling
because we were all emotional just
watching her and listening to this
letter
you know I was getting tearful for her
you knows what I'll shoot she really did
break up it was just a very sweet letter
from a boy who just really missed his
mom
all these children had absolutely no say
whether they were in the Caliphate or
not as a civilized society what do we do
just leave them there
and that's the challenge now it's what
you do with these people do they go back
to their own countries do they just
wither in a Syrian prison we don't know
but look at the aftermath look at the
the next generation of children look at
all those people millions who were under
their control how we deal with that will
set the train for what happens next
it's not over yet this is just in many
ways to start a bit you know hearing
people and their stories and the
repercussions of what's going on for the
last few years
as journalists we're going to be
covering this the aftermath for decades
to come
[Music]